do you agree with me that this is the
most sophisticated gadget on the planet
not the iPhone the I but now the
question is have you read the user's
manual as long as fear of suffering is
there within you you will never walk
your life with full stride it'll always
be half a step there are no right things
to do in life if you choose something
and put everything that you have into it
it'll become a great thing what a sore
get a mentor
[Music]
so today let's learn from one of the
best sadguru and some of his best
life-changing advice mentor me Sadhguru
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one rides the way of life is it true
that every other creature on this planet
a worm an insect a bird an animal with a
millionth of our brain they're
conducting their life process quite well
hello are they when I say live process
we are born they're born just like that
we grew up they grow up we make a living
they make a living we may reproduce they
reproduce we do all this with enormous
fuss they simply do it yes or no every
simple thing we are doing it enormous
fuss they are simply doing it different
various processes of life and death they
are doing it without fuss we are doing
everything with great fuss is this a
sign of highest level of intelligence I
am asking
we are supposed to be the most
intelligent and there is no question
that we have the most evolved
neurological process on the planet yes
we have the most evolved neurological
system that we must be able to sense and
feel and experience and perceive
understand and express things in the
highest possible way but no other
creature on the planet is struggling
like the human creature right now this
is simply because you have been given a
super supercomputer
do you agree with me that this is the
most sophisticated gadget on the planet
not the iPhone the AI but now the
question is have you read the user's
manual
that's all people have not read the
user's manual for the most complex
machine on the planet and somehow
blundering through somehow trying to use
it everything is a problem tell me one
thing that human beings are not
suffering if they're poor they suffer
their poverty you make them rich this up
of the taxes if they're not educated
they suffer that put them to school lot
of suffering not married they suffer
that get them married I didn't say
anything I didn't say a thing
okay no children some people suffered
that children daily suffering so you
seem to be suffering every aspect of
life so if you offer death will you go
do I fully know you will suffer that so
tell me one thing that we are not
suffering now people we will Asif is
life is suffering no no life is not
suffering nor is it a joy it's simply
there it's a phenomena if you write it
it feels fantastic if you're crushed by
it it feels terrible so are you riding
the wave of life or are you being
crushed by it that's all the question is
rule number two unleash your potential I
tell the story of a mane who had wings
but never used them to fly and just
reproduce and had a life and isn't it a
tragedy that he never used his wings to
fly do you feel like most of us are
walking through life with wings and we
never use them to fly unfortunately yes
a whole lot of people too many people
mm-hmm it's time that human potential is
unleashed
because we are the first generation on
the planet for whom our survival is
organized better than ever before ever
so this is the time to unlock our
potential to lose those all kinds of
inhibitions and fears that we had there
was a time if as much as cloud gathered
and lightning and thunder happened
without God was angry with us okay
okay all those things are gone it is
time you take away the nonsense that's
happening within you and the entire
process the science of inner engineering
is just this how to work at it in a
scientific manner not with philosophy I
can tell you a thousand times give up
your fear it's not going to go but if
your chemical soup is blissful
there's not even a idea of fear in your
mind it reminds me of your concept of
the movies you play the movies in your
mind you can choose a drama you can
choose a horror story or you can choose
a positive movie and not get stuck in
the same movie forever you can turn it
off and start a new one yeah but for
that you should know where the switches
are right you
like a supercomputer but you haven't
found the keyboard yet time to find the
keyboard that's my work to give people
the keyboard for their supercomputer
also if you want to have more confidence
check my 250 for confidence series it's
free the link is in the description
below it's easy to make a buck very hard
to make a difference to make changes in
any organization you have to have a
measure of very high persistency you
have to work with people where you feel
a bit insecure that's essential because
that means you're working with people
who are better than you rule number
three be fearless not a single day
passes for me right without witnessing
tears of joy and love around me every
day somebody will be shedding tears of
love and joy I don't think there's a
better way to live in this world and all
of us should strive to create our own
circles of joyfulness and pleasantness
around us because if you are not joyful
by your own nature if you are always
going around with the fear of suffering
as long as fear of suffering is there
within you you will never walk your life
with full stride it will always be half
a step most human beings have crippled
themselves simply because of fear of
suffering what will happen to me is
always the question whatever happens
this is how I will be if this assurance
comes to you only now you will want to
scale the peaks of life and see what
about it if it happens makes no
difference to you if it doesn't happen
makes no difference to you that's when
you would like to really explore every
dimension of life so first and foremost
thing is this that your way of being is
not determined by what's around you if
you bring this one aspect to you there
is no fear of suffering once there is no
fear of suffering you will traverse the
breadth and length of this life without
hesitation rule number four be
passionate about everything there are no
right things to do in life if you choose
something
and put everything that you have into it
it'll become a great thing is it the
right thing is it the best thing when
you say is it the right thing what
you're asking is is it the best thing to
do in life there is no best thing to do
in life anything that you take up and if
you put your heart and soul into it it
becomes a great thing this is the best
thing no then what is the best thing
there is no such thing don't look at
yourself as a delhi 8 or an idiot
whatever you want to call yourself if
you're just a piece of life hmm
hello and today you're here one day you
will be poop gone you are a brief life I
want to just imagine you've seen those
insights which come when it rains you
know and switch fly
suppose you are that you just came alive
gone that's what you are just compared
to the span of your life the insects
life is looking so meaningless and
poopoo coop and gone that's what the
rivers are thinking about you poopoo
cupen gone yes or no compared to their
lifespan you are just like that insect
or less than an insect isn't it so I am
NOT somebody who ever debated he is this
the right thing to do in my life what
was needed I jumped into it because if
you are a constipated life you will
always be thinking about what to do what
not to do what to do what not to do what
is my passion what is not my passion why
the hell are you not passionate about
everything
hello why are you not passionate about
everything in the existence you're only
passionate about one thing means what
you constipated that's what it means
idiots do things that they don't like to
do suffer for their whole life
because they think it's needed or they
think it's their duty intelligent people
do what they love to do they enjoy their
life to some extent but a genius learns
to do what is needed joyfully that's
when your genius flowers because it's no
more about you now there's a limitless
way of looking at life and rule number
five the last one before a very special
bonus clip is take a holiday from
seriousness just loosen up your life a
little bit laugh a little more involve
yourself with people around you do
things that you think is not so
important don't do things which are very
important do simple things very
important you do simple things very
important things you're doing in your
life you will become dead serious you
know Bertrand Russell and Englishman
Bertrand Russell said if you're
beginning to think that what you're
doing is very important you need to take
a holiday
so holiday does not mean coming to
Indiana holidays every day in those 24
hours you must take a holiday from your
seriousness from yourself seriousness
has come essentially because of your
self-importance you hold yourself as an
important person I want you to see you
are like a speck of dust in this
existence tomorrow morning if you
disappear for sure in India nobody will
miss you even Down Under they won't
bother much you know a handful of people
they will also forget soon enough isn't
it sir
nature does woof you're gone and nothing
will happen in this world everything
will happen wonderfully well even if
you're not they every human being should
be aware of this every moment of his
life it does not matter what the whole
world says about you
it does not matter how significant the
work you're doing you must understand
that tomorrow morning the world will go
on fine without you whoever you may be
isn't it so if you constantly remind
yourself of this you'll have no reason
to be serious definitely not dead and
don't be dead now a time will come it's
time to be alive now I've got a special
bonus clip on how to turn off the
problems that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the three
point landing questions let's go from
just watching the video to taking action
here we go question number one where do
you need to take a holiday from
seriousness number two how can you be
more passionate about everything and
number three where do you need to be
more fearless it's time to understand
all the problems of individual nature
are generated from with him and we don't
have to solve problems that we create we
just have to dissolve no problems that
you create you don't have to solve if
there is a problem in the situation yes
we have to solve but you have a problem
within you solution is not what you need
solution is madness solution means for
an illusion you're creating an
illusionary solution something that you
make up for that you create one more
solution that you made up once again now
you just have to turn off the problems
going through a certain drama only thing
is you're a lousy director that's all
there is instead of improving your
direction now you are trying to find a
solution for a situation in a drama it's
like people watch the cinema and come
home and they have big arguments about
what happened there
so the thoughts and emotions that you
create you don't have to find any
solution for it if you'll just turn it
off it's gone if you find solution you
moving towards insanity because you
create a ghost and you create a
Ghostbuster the ghost that you create
you must learn to play with them hello
I'm saying if nobody willing to play
with you you have to play with somebody
right so the ghosts you create if you
like them you play with them if you
don't like them turn them off but
Sadhguru they keep coming
[Applause]
you don't play don't like to play with
them don't play they come and go never
it ever happen that one thought remained
for more than a moment isn't it it comes
and goes comes and goes
let it come and go if you try to find a
solution for that you will head towards
insanity
if you want more sadguru check out the
interview that I did one-on-one with him
in this same very spot the link is right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
nobody can cause mental pain to you it
is you in reaction to something that
happens around you